et c'est en jeu du niqab aura des échos
jusqu'à l'assemblée nationale du québec
demain un appel au calme sera lancé par
québec solidaire sous la forme d'une
motion contre l'islamophobie
je joins françoise avait la co porte
parole du parti qui a déjà dirigé la
fédération des femmes du québec montceau
madame david bonsoir pourquoi
sentez-vous le besoin de lancer cet
appel au calme demain parce que on a
perdu notre calme parce que dans les
médias sociaux et je pourrais vous en
montrer des catalogues de phrases
franchement haineuse agressive
intolérants à l'égard de la communauté
musulmane parce qu' hier il ya eu une
femme à montréal qui a été bousculée
agressé par des jeunes qui voulait lui
arracher son flair de sur la tête une
femme musulmane et là moi j'en ai assez
et je voudrais que l'ensemble la classe
politique au québec et dans le fond je
pourrais en dire autant de l'ensemble
des leaders des partis fédéraux reste
calme passe à d'autres sujets que le
niqab appelle tout le monde à des à
réfléchir de tous ces sujets là ans avec
de la sérénité et dans le fond pas dans
le cadre d'une campagne électorale c'est
le pire moment pour discuter de sujets
qui viennent nous chercher dans toutes
nos émotions mais vous parlez pas du
niqab n'ya pas le mot niqab dans votre
motion pourquoi c'est pas nécessaires
justement ça fait deux semaines qu'on
nous bassine les oreilles avec la
question du niqab qui a touché
exactement deux femmes depuis quatre ans
j'aurais je reconnais que c'est une
question symbolique importante
je ne suis pas une pro niqab bien
entendu c'est une prison pour les femmes
mais enfin monsieur harper qu'est ce
qu'il est en train de faire il est entré
de se servir de quelques femmes pour
faire peur à toutes les autres femmes
il est en train de se faire passer pour
un défenseur des femmes alors qu'ils
refusent de faire une enquête sur 1200
femmes autochtones disparues
il a aboli l'équité salariale dans la
fonction publique il sait pertinemment
que l'avortement n'est pas disponible
pour l'ensemble des femmes canadiennes
et il ne fait rien monsieur harper n'est
pas un défenseur des femmes
alors oui je sais qu'ils sont
détournement la de la cause des femmes
c'est ça totalement on est complètement
utilisée dans la campagne électorale et
je voudrais
plic le 19 octobre prochain ça n'est pas
un référendum sur le niqab que nous
faisons c'est un référendum sur les neuf
ans de pouvoir d'un gouvernement
conservateur anti-femmes anti écologiste
anti travailleurs anti réfugiés mais
guerrier mais que madame david en vous
en vous positionnant contre le port du
niqab lors des cérémonies de
segmentation c'est bien ce que vous
faites vous se trouver du côté des
conservateurs vous appuyer le parti
conservateur et le bloc québécois non
sur cette question en particulier
vous savez très bien que québec
solidaire n'appuie aucun parti dans
cette campagne fédérale il peut arriver
que sur certains sujets nous appuyons
les positions d'un parti ou d'un autre
nous là ça fait quatre ans que nous
avons pris position sur le fait que les
services publics au québec par exemple
doivent être données à visage découvert
donc ça n'est pas du tout nouveau pour
nous ce que j'essaie surtout madame
galipeau de faire ce soir c'est de dire
à mes collègues du québec écoutez la
tout ce débat là est en train de créer
beaucoup d'agitation dans les médias
sociaux mais ça crée même de l'agitation
dans la rue l'homme maintenant on a des
citoyennes québécoise portant le voile
qui sont agressés ça suffit je n'accepte
pas de vivre dans un québec intolérants
gelé déjà dit au moment du débat sur la
charte des valeurs je le redis
aujourd'hui
je suggère que tout le monde respire par
le nez et qu'on fasse ces débats là dans
le plus grand calme possible en respect
évidemment des valeurs québécoises des
valeurs universelles qui sont celles du
québec dont l'égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes mais en un sens il ya
aussi haut mais son silence sur cette
histoire du niqab au québec au canada et
également oui mais là le problème c'est
que dans les médias sociaux ne se
contente pas de dire à moi je compte le
niqab c'est les musulmans sont comme si
les arabes sont comme ça il déteste les
femmes
et quand je vois qu'il ya même une
agression je me dis stop ça suffit la
danse devrait se régler en cour suprême
selon vous la question du niqab se
réglera en cour suprême mais la question
des rapports entre la majorité au québec
et ses minorités dont la minorité
musulmane
ça doit se régler au québec en dehors
d'une campagne électorale vous a bien
entendu merci madame david
merci à vous